واسمح لي ان ابدا معك بالسؤال عن تعاملكم
مع زلزال وكارثه سوريا تركيا اين تضعون
هذا الزلزال في الكوارث الطبيعيه
كارثه بيتم معنى الكلمه طبعا نحن نتعاطف
مع الضحايا والناجين واسرهم ما قمنا به
لجنه دوليه لصليب الاحمر هو الاستجابه
فورا يوم الاثنين الماضي قبل اسبوع من
خلال تقديم المساعده الطبيه للمستشفى في
حلب وكذلك
الافرشه والبطانيات للناجين
وكذلك تقديم المياه والمستلزمات الاساسيه
نتعاون مع الهلال الاحمر السعودي في تركيا
فان الهلال الاحمر التركي هو في مقدمه
الاستجابه الانساني هل هناك ايه اولويات
في حسب المنطقه الجغرافيه في سوريا او في
تركيا كيف تتعاملون مع مع هذه الازمه يعني
شرحت لنا حضرتك كيف
احب الصليب اليوم الثاني للكارثه
للملاحقه لكن هل هناك ايه اولويات
وهذا
الحيه فورا وتخفيف المعاناه ولكن ما نعلمه
هو انه في سوريا هذه الازمه جاءت لتنضم
الى ازمتين
متواجدتين منذ سنوات حاولنا ان نوفر
الحمايه ونساعد المجتمعات في سوريا بسبب
الصراع وقد تضررت من ذلك وكذلك
بتردي الاقتصاد وعدم الوصول الى الخدمات
الاساسيه نرى ان نصف الامدادات المياه لا
تعمل جيدا وفي ديسمبر تفشى وباء الكوليرا
اذا نحن نسعى لتجنب تفشي لوباء الكوليرا
من جديد من خلال توفير المياه الصالحه
للشرب وكذلك مستلزمات النظافه ما نركز
عليه هو انه حتى قبل
الزلزال قد ره المجتمع على الصمود كان
الضعيفه للغايه
والاحتياجات الاساسيه كانت على شفاء
الانهيار وبالتالي هذه ازمه جاءت لتفاقم
ازمات اخرى وتضع سبل العيش للمجتمعات في
وضع بالغ الصعوبه